hello and welcome to this video playing
a Rizzo 19 here its own 90 it's got
really weird bullet writing anyway we'll
see what happens one of my pet lines
cactus earlier on the channel yeah the
Queen trait I think this is the position
that probably would have been evaluated
at nothing special for white like 25-30
years ago but nowadays we appreciate
that white is probably just a bit better
here the H file is really nice to have
and black has some potential weaknesses
hmm I just wonder if I should play e5
here in this particular situation you
play 95 I go Knight e4 a5 these kind of
things I wonder if this is right he will
play d5 next that's pretty clear which
is probably going to be answered by
maybe five
I have another idea f 3d 5d 4d takes e4
g5a here Bishop d2 1d takes d4 Knight e4
is also better for white because the
bishop is attacked so D takes Knight
takes Knight takes bishop before so yeah
now I get in g5 although no it's a good
move let's do it and now you can think
about this one
angling for Knight a for the right
moment
and it's not much fun for like this kind
of situation II cannot cancel short
kingi seven gets immediately killed it's
not a lot of fun so what do you do now
with white I can just go a3 as a simple
choice get rid of this the situation but
I can also play Knight e4 immediately
yeah it's it's it's important not to
spend too much time you're going to be a
bit better almost no matter what and
spend too much time it doesn't help okay
Bishop d6 I'm expecting to happen and
then ya have four maybe
just speed up a little bit
uh-huh interesting yeah I should I
should open this up if he takes with the
C pawn I'm going to gain the be 5 square
which will be really nice and it takes
I've got rupee 1 and no I don't know now
he has to go back basically it should be
8 don't think he can afford to take give
me that
the pair of Bishops but maybe maybe
maybe you still reasonably solid song
should be eight Wow it allows me to take
that seems odd
I should be four check
yeah how to do that it's interesting
couple of things if it takes F takes the
F pawn it's very weak I wonder hoops III
in this position sometimes let's see
what he does
there is also f5 as a send additional
idea okay so here what check out this so
no tough for him to save the a at the F
pawn
mm if I take f7 there is rook h1
checkmate
I shouldn't do that
I may be Bishop e7 was good hmm maybe
okay so 94 is going to happen
hmm it's a little bit it's not ideal
that same
maybe look f7 immediately using the spin
gets a dominating bishop position no the
G porn can't run okay yeah that looked
like the alley clean victory yeah that
Queen g3 is an interesting variation
it's the same game doesn't look very
dangerous but it's not easy for black at
all to play the went Knights is six and
they decided to take it and play of 3e
five is certainly possible it's
something I of course I considered and
that I mentioned here I was thinking
that maybe a five is a move but the
computer likes white and okay white
white should be better him I see the
point like this must be better I just
have the better plan structure a pawn
and h-bond are both weak yes he has a
center but not easy to play f3 g 5g for
was my idea so that after this g5 9594
is going to be really great the
development we should be form 52 yeah
now taking is really good for white
something like this is great okay went
Bishop d7 I went to g5 long a 583 looks
like decent decent moves 6 f4 is really
much really not liked by the engine yeah
thinking about it why not take on d5 now
I'm definitely possible definitely
possible
with a similar game like here but
without allowing him something yeah
let's maybe this but this is
this is really disastrous it looks
terrible what is really am ruling the
whole board with the two bishops in now
so King e7 and this is just giving me
this one Jim this is a winning position
I maybe maybe I missed ways to win
quicker it's definitely possible
I think this is I don't think I made a
huge blunder anyway anywhere you'd hear
this really just completely over three
points and black hands no play the
bishop he is so much stronger than the
night okay guys thanks for watching